la stratégie roussel c'est d'essayer de
partir à la reconquête de l'électorat
populaire du côté gauche pour le coup
avec des thèmes qui étaient ceux du
parti communiste dans les années 60 70
enfin tout ça a changé très récemment à
partir du moment où le parti communiste
devenait déjà un parti de progrès le
progressiste de robert hue et c'est donc
qu'il revient aux fondamentaux ça fait
mal évidemment puisque la gauche
aujourd'hui est empêtré dans les 50
nuance de oki sme et de gauchisme
d'ailleurs mangé du saucisson boire du
vin c'est vu comme étant un signe du
patriarcat blanc oppressif pour certains
donc c'est compliqué évidemment de
sortir une bouteille de pinard et du
sauciflard donc pour fabien roussel
c'est un choix politique qui peut
évidemment l'aider à se positionner au
sein de l'électorat populaire après à
gauche c'est une autre histoire après je
pense qu'il reste un vrai marxiste
léniniste qui se dit que le wookie semer
encore une maladie infantile du
socialisme aujourd'hui et que c'est pas
ça que veulent ces électeurs qui veulent
d'abord de la justice sociale qui en ont
assez des inégalités des inégalités
réelles socio-économique et pas des
inégalités fantasmé par des par des
professeurs d'université
tu es horizon des fadaises auquel ils
veulent croire donc il a raison d'aller
se dresser à cet électorat là qui a été
préempté en partie par marine le pen est
un peu par jean-luc attachement à la
dernière élection mais il ne va plus sur
ce terrain là donc je pense que d'aller
s'adresser à cette france périphérie
populaire wallon ali rapporter des
points à 1 fabien roussel
[Musique]